-You talk a lot,
not just in the book
but also on your podcast,
about the elections in November.
How much confidence do you think
the American people can have
in a fair election right now
And I do think, you know,
sometimes we talk about it
it's a little dangerous,
because obviously
the Trump administration,
based on the outcome,
will also speak to the ide
that it was not fair.
So, how do you frame it
so that it just doesn't become
a thing that everyone
can sort of use
for their own best interests
-Yeah.
I mean, everyone is going to
claim that it's rigged.
That was the little trick
they pulled in 2016
by, you know, Trump constantly
saying it was rigged.
It forced the Democrats
into this position
where they're like,
"It can't be rigged."
And then, when it was,
in some respects rigged,
they really had nothing to say
What they should be doing
is pushing
for election transparency
and integrity early.
They should be pushing
for vote by mail,
because of the coronavirus
because of the dangers
we are being put in
by having physical voting.
I've been worried about
the integrity of this election
for a long time,
before the virus came around
I've been worried about
domestic voter suppression
foreign interference,
insecure machines,
and Trump
simply refusing to leave.
My new worry is that perhaps
the election will be delayed
or kind of
indefinitely postponed.
Usually, even autocrats
love elections.
You know, they like to hav
a fake election
so that they can brag abou
the people's love.
And I didn't think
that Trump would turn down
an opportunity to do that.
But given this unprecedented
public-health crisis,
it's uncertain
what direction he'll go.
-Don't take this the wrong way
There is a core pessimism to
a lot of what you write about.
But do you feel as though
there might be a chance
to come through this
on the other side
with a changed perspective
from the American people?
And where do you find optimism
-Yeah, I mean,
I don't think about it so much
in terms
of optimism or pessimism
or hope or hopelessness.
I just try to do
the right thing.
You know, when you have
so much chaos,
when you have
so much instability,
you really have to look
at your morals
and your principles
and how you treat people
and the kind of life
that you want to lead.
And so I just try
to do the right thing.
I do try to make suggestions
that are helpful
in that respect.
But I'm not going to have
blind faith
in eroding institutions
that we've already seen fail
You know, what Americans,
I think, have recognized by now,
the institutions
are only as good
as the people
who are willing to uphold them
And sometimes they have
to uphold those institutions
in the face of profound
and unprecedented threats.
And so far,
that has not really happened
That doesn't mean it's too late.
It doesn't mean
that we're doomed.
It does mean we're in
for a rough ride
and that we really
have to get our bearings
and focus always on telling th
truth and treating people right.
-Thank you so much, Sarah,
for making time for us again
Obviously, I wish
this would be in the studio.
And hopefully, next time,
it'll be in person.
Please check out Sarah's new
book "Hiding in Plain Sight.
We've got a couple of copies
[ Laughs ]
And we'll be right back
with more "Late Night."
Thanks, Sarah.